you want to see the anatomy of a fake
news headline
this was a headline in variety magazine
trade magazine in hollywood this was
syndicated into yahoo
said spotify lost more than 2 billion
in market value after neil young pulled
his music over joe rogan's podcast
this is this should be framed as a fake
news article par excellence
it's so effective because
it's technically
almost kind of true
if you just look at the days
sometime around when neil young made his
announcement
the spotify number went down
spotify stock down
that's true
but correlation is not causation the
reason that spotify lost two billion
dollars in market value
is because the entire market was down
significantly
virtually every company lost a ton of
market value if you just look at the one
or two day period
did ge lose value because neil young
said he was going to pull his music from
spotify
did uh
i don't know did did ford motor company
lose value did microsoft lose value
because no of course not
it went down and actually it's even
crazier than that because if you look
specifically after the in the two days
after neil young made his announcement
spotify actually ticked up a little bit
so maybe that should be evidence that
neil young was dragging down spotify and
the market loves rogan or really maybe
there's just no correlation here the
scary part though is the libs are
circling the wagons on this
the the news media are in on it big tech
is slowly in on it the culture obviously
and the public health establishment
which is the
the puppet master in this whole thing
right everybody joni mitchell neil young
they're all doing faucets bidding here
and saying we can't dissent against the
the ruling class and the bureaucracy
so it's good that spotify for now is
standing up for rogan i'm not sure that
that lasts i do think that we need to
defend joe rogan at all costs
defend rogan if rogan goes they're
coming for the rest of us
too
and what's so frustrating about it is
it's not even the
apparent hypocrisy on free speech it's
not even the the fact that uh joe rogan
and the guests that rogan brings on have
more credibility than dr vaouji or
rochelle wallensky because because
fouchy and walensky and joe biden have
been caught in so many lies on kovid
it's the fact that neil young and joni
mitchell are just wrong
on the merits they're wrong on the
substance here long time listeners to
this show know that i am allergic to
going to the gym i have not been to the
gym
i think probably since the obama
administration i i hate it because you
you have to drive what 20 minutes to the
gym then you go you get out you get on
the equipment you
you do your thing for however long then
you go you gotta change shower get back
drive 20. it just takes too long what if
you bring the gym home that's what
echelon does echelon fitness is the
affordable way to get the workout
equipment the workout community and an
instructor's motivation right in the
comfort and privacy of your own home
with echelon fitness you can work at any
time day or night and crush your fitness
goals pick your class climb the
leaderboard cheer each other on and give
it your all echelon fitness's full range
of affordable workout equipment
including stationary bikes smart rowers
sleek fitness screens
and the auto folding treadmill are all
connected to provide the echelon fitness
experience right now for a limited time
our listeners get up to 650 off msrp i
love my echelon i really really
recommend this to get the exclusive
podcast discount text knowles canon wles
to 818181
text knowles right now do it right now
if you're even slightly somewhat
interested i'm telling you you will not
regret it text knowles canon wles to
81-81-81 to get up to 650 off msrp text
knolls to 818181 message and data rates
may apply terms available at
echelonfit.com sms membership sold
separately
ring my bell ll ring my
bell right there ring it subscribe get
notifications even though sometimes
our friends here at youtube don't send
those notifications even when you do
subscribe which is why you got to go to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts
subscribe
to the michael knowles show maybe leave
a five star review we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you